celui qui répond bien à deux questions
gagner le jeu alors comme syrie et le
champion le challenger le droit de
donner une réponse au premier si c'est
la bonne
il marque le point on passe à la
question suivante d'accord y compris
henriette première question question
sciences et vie de la terre
quels organes du corps humain est
composé de deux oreillettes et de deux
ventricules je le sais le cas raitt et
ça c'est une bonne réponse juste pour
savoir qui est pour moi qui ai pour
janvier vous le saviez vous
bien sûr on vous et vos amis et vos
familles vos gens me bon vous oui vous
vos cyril jean-mi niveau professionnel
vous largement et je sais qu'elle est
toujours contre moi donc c'est jean
louis mahé elle est contente plus droit
à l'erreur pour cirer la deuxième
question question géographique 1,5
milliard à la devise est inscrite sur le
drapeau du brésil
alors je sais c'est déjà trop tard
déjà prix ord m2 dans les médias odem
bas partout garde il faut le la toile
alors est ce que je sais juste oui mais
je m'en fous j'ai chéri je sais qu'il
fait très chaud d'heure je crois qu'on a
une caméra d'or juste pouvoir s'il fait
toujours aussi chaud
oui c'est vrai quoi la manche au dehors
est ce qu'on peut vérifier wee aa oui
oui ah bah oui regardez fait tellement
chaud il ya des gens qui autorise mais
n'en a vendu 2 6 mais oui mais oui mais
non voix oui ah oui ordonne époux les
progrès sont voilà oui non vous n'avez
pas honte
un homme pour l'instant tout va bien
quelle devise d'inscrits sur le drapeau
du brésil syrie c'est à vous de répondre
je verrai dont les woerth m ouais ouais
je crois que c'est hors d'elle
ces projets sont progression au bout ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire si tu dors
tu va progresser un qui a de l'or dans
ta chance d'orange mentale chez vous par
les portugais depuis combien de temps
vous l'a écouté les formes ont ça va
vous paraître étonnant mais la devise du
drapeau du brésil c'est ordem et
progresso du mans
[Applaudissements]
à
non
[Applaudissements]
oui oui oui je lui a jeté l'émoi
apparemment que bonjour de quelqu'un
j'ai beau amateurs
des cas qui ramené mon bac 1 oui juste
les gars quand vous faites un faux bac
c'est la lumière bac en sciences
j'avais eu un bac en sciences
économiques et sociales je sais pas du
tout c'est un acte des epn 74
merci mamie âge et surtout vous l'avez
eu comme en 2001 à 26 ans tout se joue
sur cette question histoire histoire
plateforme en histoire tous les deux
devraient corriger des notions alors
dans le calendrier républicain quel nom
était attribuée au 25e jour du mois de
germinal exactement temps des demies ce
que enfin j'ai pas dit ça c'est pas du
tout là dessus on me dit qu'en fait
juste parce que j'ai un truc en fait il
ya quelqu'un qui voudrait en parler
oui allô non qui souhaitent à sion
qu'est ce que vous avez à sion
[Applaudissements]
alors la question c'était dans le
calendrier républicain quel nom était
attribuée au 25e jour du mois de
germinal ne serait pas non plus petits
jouent alors pigeons
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ma fille mais pas les séries je suis le
seul animateur à faire l'émission
occupation
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]